what exactly are white people good at  that is a question  being asked in a video that has gone  very viral on a huge youtube channel it  starts out  funny enough what are white people  superior at  [Laughter]  they they just keep talking mostly about  their pets white people love day dogs  like that's all you see  men like making cereal casseroles making  bland food unseasoned chicken okay so it  starts out funny enough but then the  video takes a turn white people are very  superior at their privilege we do not  have the privilege to do whatever and  however we want to being ignorant blame  feeling victimized playing the victim  congratulating themselves over  that they're incompetent at or that  should have already been done they're  superior at being  whoa that's some pretty bigoted stuff  right there isn't it these people are  pretty vicious racial bigots aren't they